ok very different diverging
predictions increases and decreases
which we wouldn't capture from the GCMs
but in order to be able to do even
better I just wanted to highlight very
quickly I think a couple of knowledge
gaps things that we really need to know
better the first is that I've already
made an argument that we need to
characterize the transmission
environment we need to know what it is
that mosquitoes are experiencing we're
still using even in our studies here met
station data to help define mean
temperatures and Donald temperature
range but mosquito and met stations are
often placed at airports but mosquitoes
don't live next to met stations at
airports mosquitoes live in places like
this so we get so we've got we
understand very little there are very
very few environmental data that
actually tell us this is a transmission
site in Chennai well in India this is a
transmission site in urban Chennai this
is in banane this is in Kenya we have no
environmental data that tells us what
the mosquitoes actually experiencing in
these environments ok if it's indoors
versus outdoors it's going to be
experiencing different environments if
it's indoors it's going to be different
depending on whether it's a thatched
roof this is a tin roof if it's outdoors
it's going to differ whether it's a
Hubley every vegetated area versus
sparsely vegetated if we're talking
about aquatic habitats it's going to
make a big difference depending on
whether the larval habitat is an
overhead concrete tank versus if it's a
puddle in a tire track we don't actually
know we have not done a very good job of
characterizing the environmental
conditions that mosquito is living with
no mosquitoes transmit malaria for over
100 years we've done a very good job of
very poor job I think of characterizing
the environment and characterizing their
biology